Sky News has commissioned a labour
members poll from YouGov as we enter the
final phase of the race and for the
first time we've been able to include
the views of trade unionists and others
eligible to vote in this poll and the
results couldn't be clearer the poll
suggests sakir stahma wins convincingly
in the first round by securing over 50
percent of the vote Rebecca long Bailey
is trailing in second place on 31% and
Lisa Nandi quick far behind on 16% the
figures suggest sakir is doing a smidgen
better that he was in mid-january when
this poll was last done
look how convincingly the shadow brexit
secretary wins by in so many of the key
categories now what you're looking at
now is the size of the lead securing
choice over miss long bailey amongst
different groups he does better amongst
women than men although he wins both
convincingly older members are more in
favor of sakir as our remain voters and
intriguingly trade unionists remember
just how strongly the trade unions used
to support Jeremy Corbyn while he was in
office but are now voting for change but
look here Rebecca long bailey has a lead
amongst labour members who voted for
brexit in 2016 and a huge advantage
amongst labour members who are part of
momentum there's one other revealing bit
of data here this shows how labour
members are likely to vote in this
contest depends on when they joined the
party now if you're in labour in the
Tony Blair Gordon Brown or Ed Miliband
areas you want Kearse dama
however if you joined while jeremy
corbyn was in the hot seat
you're more likely to favor Rebecca long
bailey but look at this if you join
since the December election drubbing and
the campaign's think around a hundred
thousand people have signed up since
then then you are overwhelmingly in
favor of Kearse Tama rather than the
korbinite choice of Rebecca long bailey
it appears people who want labour to
change direction have joined up in
droves in the last two months to take
back control from the corbin wing of the
party